woo Chi Chi is one of the last master
craftsmen of neon signage in Hong Kong
businesspeople bring him their
hand-drawn designs then he makes the
neon signs that Hong Kong is famous for
he works with glass tubes which he
painstakingly bends in to shape its
precision work who found his profession
by chance it was the summer holidays and
I was 18 my father thought I was doing
nothing so he got me a job with the neon
sign maker Wu was offered the
opportunity to stay on and he decided
not to go back to school it's quite a
challenge to form the complicated
Chinese characters the work has remained
the same
bending the glass attaching the ignition
coil and filling the tube with
fluorescent gas all is done by hand but
for Wu much has changed up until 15 or
20 years ago I worked every day for
seven or eight hours making neon tubes
today it's maybe four or five days a
month his income now comes mainly from
other jobs the neon signs that used to
be Hong Kong's trademark are becoming a
rare sight Cardon chan has been
documenting those that remain
closer to the Hongkong that I used to
know
she runs a group that hopes to protect
Hong Kong's neon heritage many old signs
have been taken down because of new
safely regulations and a cheaper
alternative to neon is replacing those
that remain the blue and yellow one here
actually they're LEDs and in the 1000
you could actually compare the signs
symbolize wealth in a city that once set
trends for the rest of the continent
4chan a part of Hong Kong's identity is
fading
and it may not be coming back
Hong Kong is a changing city many people
from Hong Kong fear a loss of political
and cultural independence carton Chan
wants to keep the craft of bending neon
glass alive so she's planning workshops
with master craftsmen Wu Chi Chi things
change we have to accept this I think
the key is for us to find new uses for
neon lights for example using them as
lamps and decorations for interior
design perhaps Wu's vision may be the
best way to avoid losing an art form so
closely linked to Hong Kong